james comey broke
fbi rules but the justice department
they will not
prosecute him a scathing new doj
inspector general report details how the
former fbi director
handled memos about president trump the
report laying out numerous violations by
comey among them comey violated policy
by giving one memo to a friend with
instructions to share it with the new
york times
he also kept copies of the memos in a
safe at his home
the inspector general saying the former
head of the fbi said a quote
dangerous example for the bureau but
comey
he's insisting he's been cleared and
even taunting his critics
here i'm quoting and to all those who've
spent two years talking about me
going to jail or being a liar and a
leaker
ask yourselves why you still trust
people who gave you bad info for so long
including the president president trump
he's responding by saying comey
should be ashamed of himself uh
as someone who's been in our congress
i'm going to ask you
do you agree with what the inspector
general found in the decision not to
prosecute
i wish well the inspector general
recommended that he
be prosecuted it's the department of
justice in
operating at a different level that has
decided not to do this
i find it very troubling that there are
multiple times where the inspector
general has made recommendations to
prosecute
including the deputy assistant director
and others
and they haven't prosecuted i think
that's a problem i think it's a terrible
precedent
i think michael horowitz who was
confirmed unanimously as an obama
appointee did a very thorough job
but if james comey thinks that he has
has
won the day are you kidding me the first
report on him said that
you know he acted as insubordinate uh
this is as damning as any report you'll
ever see from an inspector general
and i do think they should have
prosecuted but james comey is not out of
the woods yet
you have two vote places of
vulnerability one
is actually the chief justice of the
supreme court because once the inspector
general does the fisa report
they could very well hold people in
contempt and james comey's autograph is
on one of those things
and the supreme court should actually
hold them accountable for
misleading on the fisa the fisa abuse
the second one is the report on the fisa
abuse james comey is not out of the
woods on that
but we haven't seen anything out of all
that talk about fisa warrants and the
like to this point and dana
justin asking about this do what do you
think should be the penalty he did
according to the report violate policy
but they're saying
he didn't break the law apparently these
memos were not classified
so this feels a lot to me like something
that happened
back in 2015 and 16 when he was the fbi
director
he's doing a victory lap sort of like
hillary clinton did a victory lap
after he james comey declined to
officially charge her
for having the private email server and
a lot of these things are
very similar right the retention and
handling of government
documents it's almost as if it's kind of
the mirror image
because it's the same statute or the
same
policy guideline that he decided not to
officially charge and now the justice
department is saying we're not going to
prosecute
but nobody's saying this is a good thing
to do i have a feeling that if
somebody that worked for jim comey at
the fbi had done this very thing and jim
comey found out about it that person
would probably have been fired or at
least
put on a suspension and while there is
investigation
but but his tweet i have to say uh
it's it's good to be on offense if you
can be so even when it looks like you
should be on defense he's just on
offense and he learned that from
like our recent politics it works yeah
well you mean you learned that from
president trump
and not only that i mean i think that if
you look at hillary clinton she walked
out of that
jim coney basically said she did all of
these terrible things and she walked out
saying i'm good
well yeah how dare how dare you anybody
say that i did something wrong
so you know greg i was thinking though
that democrats are angry at jim comey
because it was 10 days before the
election when he came out
and sent a letter to congress saying i'm
going to reopen this investigation never
mentioning that there was an ongoing
probe into trump's campaign so do you
think
right now when you look at this and you
say you know he was talking to the
president the president was asking him
to go
light on mike flynn do you see any way
to justify his behavior or do you think
i will get away always give comey credit
for
having both sides hate him he's managed
to piss off
everybody so there's something kind of
redeeming about somebody everybody hates
from a personal viewpoint um but i have
to go back to this victory lap
right it was a one-man vic you know what
it is it was a one-man fist bump
he just went up like this there's nobody
there there's nobody there to fist bump
like congrats he's doing a one-man
high-five um
this he's claiming victory it reminds me
of me
like claiming victory when my wife finds
only four empty beer bottles
and not eight i mean yeah they only got
me for leaking phony stuff to the press
and i'm not going
to jail i win my worry is i hope this
doesn't hinder his chances
in becoming a cnn contributor because i
think he just
proved them right but what did we learn
from that what did we learn from what he
did wrong
so he designated a buddy to leak info uh
from the fbi to the new york times
that this was a guy who was always
interested in the media piece
more than anything he was always into
the spotlight
and he always used to cover it up in
this aw shucks jolly
g williker's andy griffith show
mentality but that
camouflage a narcissistic man he should
go to jail for life dana
if there was the death penalty i'd push
for it this is double deep state
double deep state or maybe it's
deep double state either way it's deep
dish
double state space space theater
deep fish deep dish this is a deep dish
double state
can i just piggyback on what you were
saying piggyback on my deep state
yes no i don't i don't think that
but just that yeah the hubris the
narcissism and this ig report you're
exactly right it's as damian as they
come
it was one big what were you thinking so
in terms of
you know let's go through the findings
so first of all no it's not your
personal diary
that's still classified information and
the ig comes out and says
literally wholly uh unsubstantiated in
law
as well as plainly stated in the code so
you would think an acting director would
understand that right
and in terms of disseminating that
classified information his defense in
these interviews during the
investigation was
well i did it because i love my country
meanwhile all of the other actors went
on the record saying they were shocked
and stunned
and disappointed and surprised so the ig
was like you're not a whistleblower bro
you were just straight up broke the law
and you broke policy
and they the fbi learned about him
giving the memos to his attorneys
literally during his congressional
testimonies
and all of those guys baker and struck
they were calling during the
the testimony to try to get that
classified information
let me interrupt you for a second his
argument was and i think that what the
report says this these were not
classified documents
and the answer was yes they were yes
they were they were subsequently maybe
classified but not when he and also
usually what happened i know but it's
not like he was writing down his to-do
list of like things he needed to do
around the house he was writing
actual information that had to do with
his government with his president
and you can't just say that those are
not government documents as a press
secretary
you take down notes in a meeting those
those notes have to go into the file
but here's the point but here's my
records and classifiers here's my point
to you this is a trump justice
department that just made this decision
that in fact he is not to be prosecuted
i will say this
in answer that they declined to
prosecute this but presently we have the
ig
investigating the fbi for their conduct
during the entire investigation we also
have
two separate investigations by the doj
by the u.s attorney for connecticut and
top intelligence officials
into the origins of the mueller probe he
is not
out of the clear or whatever it is it
sounds to me like you guys
you guys are wishing that they had
caught him but they didn't catch him but
jason before we go
not over andrew mccabe where does that
sit now because again
there's been no prosecution cnn two
things that happened
yeah see you then two things real
quickly
uh by separating out james comey there
are a lot of people behind the scenes
that believe that that is
really bad news for mccabe strzok page
or this list of characters if they're
going to treat comey and
give them a pass these others have a
great deal of vulnerability ahead of
them and the second point i'd like to
make is
what i worry i think the obama biden
legacy is going to be the politicization
putting politics into the worst of the
worst
you're you're supposed to have an fbi a
department of justice
the irs the federal reserve they're all
supposed to be
above and beyond politics and yet where
we are
eight years later nine years later is
they have politicized
some of the institutions that should be
on politics if there's nothing else from
james comey and what you saw in the
first
and second report from the ig is that
they use this for their own personal
gratification their own personal
political agenda
and they politicize these departments
and agencies and that's in part what's
tearing up this country because they
don't believe there's an equal
application
of justice under the law to summarize
that
thanks obama there you go but you
realize jim comey's a republican
yeah right okay he has not you know he
raised
he was donating what did he donate
thousand dollars to democrats i don't
know what he did the other thing that
added to the list of where he has been
disingenuous he is no republican no
conservative
the guy is clearly in the democratic
record says he's a conservative and a
republican
and the same thing you know i mean you
stop and look at
robert mueller he's a republican to
greg's point we both don't
we both are upset with him and hillary
clinton he screwed over hillary clinton
and he has screwed over the department
of justice he has made the situation
worse
no matter how you look at it all right